todavía no llegó el momento que pueden
respirar tranquilos los 6000 indígenas y
un campamento viniendo a 170 pueblos
distintos en brasilia hoy a la espera de
un juicio para los indígenas choclán es
la causa daría seguridad jurídica a
todas las tierras indígenas y todas las
reservas del país por eso los pueblos
originarios del país están acá esperando
que la suprema corte decida sobre esta
causa para dormir tranquilos y para no
avance el plan del agronegocio brasileño
sobre las tierras indígenas brasileñas
para que los planes del gobierno
bolsonaro explotación financiera y
económica de zonas de reservas indígenas
no avancen y estas tierras quieren
demarcadas por un marco legal que les
daría mucho más seguridad
y el supremo tribunal federal no logró
llegar hasta el juicio manteniendo en la
agenda otros juicios paralelos la
expectativa es para mañana que retomen
el juicio y que llegue una decisión que
dé a estos pueblos originaron un marco
legal para la demarcación de tierras
indígenas en el país